OLIVER OGG: Good morning.
Hello, everyone, and welcome
to the Apigee online meetup.
My name is Oliver and I
will be your host today.
Because of the
current situation,
again, we are broadcasting from
our respective homes instead
of the London offices.
And we're very excited
to have you join us today
for our conversation.
Today marks our 10th
Apigee online meetup, back
by popular demand.
It is our goal to be
as interactive and as
educational as possible.
The region we broadcast
to is diverse,
so I look forward to your
perspectives, your comments
and questions, throughout
today's session.
We've got a lot to
get through today.
So after this
introduction, I'm going
to give a short introduction to
running an API-first platform
business.
And then we'll hear
from Simon, who
will talk about driving
commercial impact
with a true platform strategy.
We'll then, at
about halfway point,
have an opportunity to
take questions from you.
We'll then roll into our
fireside chat between Simon
and myself, and then
towards the end,
have another opportunity
to answer questions
from yourselves.
So there's lots of
opportunity to ask questions
throughout this session.
Please don't just wait
towards these windows
or towards the end of the
meetup to ask those questions.
Please, as we go forward,
if something comes to mind,
please do ask them in
the ON24 tool here.
Today speaker-- I'm very pleased
to say that, we're joined today
by Simon Torrance.
Simon is the creator of
"The New Growth Playbook,"
co-founder of the
platform Economy Summit,
and co-author of "FightBack--
How to Win in a Digital Economy
with Platforms, Ventures,
and Entrepreneurs."
So without further ado,
get yourself comfortable.
Let's get started.
So to warm things up and get
everybody on the same page,
let's talk about API-first
platform businesses--
executing with that
platform mindset.
For the digital native
platform businesses,
like Google, APIs
are in our DNA.
It is how we share data
within the business
and outside the business.
There are substantial commercial
and transformative effects
if you execute well.
I'll touch on some key
examples of business outcomes
our customers have realized
as a result of executing well.
Now, one of the
challenges around APIs
is the fact that they've been
around for such a long time.
People's perspective of them is
that they're about technology
and integration and access--
this left hand side
of this sliding scale.
Apigee and myself
spent a lot of time
helping customers really think
about this right hand side,
where these
substantial effects can
be realized because now a
business can efficiently
participate in vibrant
digital ecosystems--
experiment, launch new
business models, new ventures
and monetize in new
and different ways.
The organizations
that do this well
are where APIs aren't
just in the periphery.
APIs are now central to
everything that they do,
this API-first culture.
So APIs are built by
default. But APIs are just
how data is shared
through the business
and in and out of that business.
Many of you will be familiar
with that Jeff Bezos mandate
in 2002, no less.
Now that really launched that
API-first culture in Amazon.
And most industry
observers would
say that that was
key to how Amazon
has shown extraordinary growth
and adaptability and resilience
as that business has evolved.
These are sort of examples
where business realizes
network effects of growth, new
revenue streams, resilience
and adaptability.
There are other, larger
financial incentives
to execute a platform strategy.
McKinsey believes that by 2025--
so not that far
away-- $60 trillion
is going to flow through
digital platforms.
Benzell, Lagarda, and Van
Alstyne in that academic paper
called "The Impact of
APIs in Firm Performance"
talk about a number
of benefits--
financial benefits--
to an organization.
And the call out
there is that they
believe that you can achieve
a 12% increase in market
capitalization if
you execute well.
Now, there are more tangible,
more immediate business
outcomes, which I'll
touch on in a moment.
So an API Platform and
strategically placing them
in the heart of your
business enables
you to control and
enable the flow of data
through supply and demand.
Let's go through supply here.
So it may well be
that you already today
have a rich catalog of
products and services,
perhaps from lots
of different parts
of the business, if you're
a large group company.
For many of our customers, it
is about aggregating supply
from partners and startups.
So for example, leveraging
another company's
products and services,
or indeed, content.
Many of our customers are
trying to interact much more
efficiently with
other industries--
telcos, banks, logistics,
classic examples
of where a business now needs to
be very efficiently interacting
with other industries.
And of course, things
at the bottom there,
for particularly like technology
companies, smart cities,
telcos, there's often a huge
fleet of devices and sensors
out there.
And you need to
aggregate that data
and flow it into the business.
And then demand--
so again, partners.
It may well be that a channel
for your products and services
will be strategic partners.
It might be the long
tail through third party
applications and developers.
Social channels, of
which there's always
a new one popping up
every couple of years.
Of course, omnichannel
and devices of all sorts.
And of course, mobile channels.
So by strategically placing
that API platform in the middle,
it enables you to insert
that control plane
as data flows in and out and
through the organization.
It enables you to
govern that data,
protect it, but also unlock
it where appropriate.
Package it.
Productize it.
And monetize it.
Now, monetization is
a key data strategy.
And it's often routed around
some sort of partner strategy.
This enables you now to create
these highly unusual assets,
these APIs.
And it enables you to
decouple old and new worlds,
or different parts of
that demand-supply balance
that want to operate
at different speeds.
Simon is going to talk about
this model of supply and demand
a little bit more.
He's also going to talk
about innovation models
that you can drive
into corporate.
APIs really help an
organization and unlock
that innovation
whilst also leveraging
those efficiencies of
scale, those assets
that an enterprise has.
Data is fundamental here.
So APIs and this API layer gives
you this unique opportunity
in capturing data consistently--
large, large volumes of data.
So it is also important that
you're capturing that data,
you're not scared of
the volumes of data,
that you are
democratizing that data,
and you are giving the different
teams within your business
that data so they
can drive insight
into their different
product areas.
This slide emphasizes
now this future state
for organizations that they
are becoming orchestrators,
facilitators between
supply and demand,
facilitating highly
efficient transactions.
I talked about some
tangible commercial effects
that some of our businesses--
some of our customers
have realized.
To partners is a key KPI
for many of our customers,
often coming from a world where
onboarding used to take years,
if not several months.
So this is a KPI
from a telco where
they could increase the time--
they could reduce, sorry, the
time to on board from two years
to two weeks.
Now, that is an
important KPI for anybody
on a journey of a
partner eco-system.
Scale-- a technology
company we work with
runs a platform at 10x the scale
of other projects with 1/10
the workforce because that
platform there gives you
a unique opportunity to
facilitate these large groups
of supply and demand.
Optionality-- so it's not
just about speed here.
It's also the cost in
which to do something.
So this comes from
a retailer where
they could increase the
frequency of different channel
deployments by 30 times.
That meant, for example,
that they could also
quickly and cheaply launch
new products, new offerings,
digital offerings
to their customers
to validate as to
whether they were
going to be impactful
products in their own right.
New call center applications,
new mobile applications--
these were complex apps
built within weeks.
And lastly, products
and services--
a retailer here increased their
product count 10x from 50,000
to 1.5 million SKUs,
product variants.
And they did that
within the first year
of launching their marketplace,
the marketplace being
a type of platform strategy.
So these are kind of
good examples of KPIs
that excite the business
community today.
I want to call out two customers
that are really demonstrating
this phenomenally well.
In the world of retail,
Magalu, Magazine Louiza,
based in Brazil.
And in the world of
financial services,
Arity, which spun
out of Allstate.
They also showed two
very different examples
of driving innovation within
your business, of which Simon
will go into in more detail.
Magalu reinvented
themselves, moving
from a traditional
world of transformation
where you're a
physical retailer.
With omnichannel, they
now see themselves
as that digital platform
with a physical presence.
And Allstate that had a
connected car program running
for many years recognized that
they should spin out Arity
so that it could execute
autonomously from the parent.
Simon will touch on those
two types of innovations.
So with Magalu,
this is an example
of a customer that has realized
those market capitalization
increases if you look
at their stock price
over the last few years.
This is a business
really focused
on this and that
partner ecosystem.
They used to sell tens
of thousands of SKUs.
They now sell 13
million products.
They have 15,000 sellers
on their platform,
complex partners on board
within only two weeks.
Apigee helps you onboard
those partners efficiently.
And since the last four years,
they've seen between 60% to 76%
year on year growth
in e-commerce.
With Arity, now, that connected
car program within Allstate
had a vast volume of data.
But they recognized that there
were some industry challenges
that they wanted to solve
by unlocking this data
and monetizing their data.
So they wanted to
better understand
risk, and more precisely,
price insurance.
That means they need
the best insights, which
means they need the most data.
So by not just using
the data from the parent
but opening up their APIs to
all sorts of participants,
it means that they can Hoover up
much more data, thereby driving
much more insights
through their models,
and thereby making a much more
compelling service of which
they monetize.
They sit on over 85 years
worth of claims frequency
and severity data, 10
years of experience
capturing telematics data,
these sensors in things
like phones and cars, 35 billion
miles of driving data built
into these models.
They partner with mapping
companies and weather
companies.
Customers include financial
services customers,
transportation, ridesharing
companies, automakers,
and government.
So this is a great example of a
virtuous cycle of data flowing
in and out of the business.
They've even signed
up a competitor
to their parent, Allstate,
because they just
need more data, which just
makes them more valuable.
Right.
Thank you.
And now I'd like to
hand over to Simon.
SIMON TORRANCE: Thanks
very much, Olly.
Very good to be here.
So I'm going to
talk about really
what this picture shows here.
And you recognize that symbol.
How can we, as
incumbent businesses,
release the inner
digital Superman
so we can create new
growth and value?
And we're sort of trapped
within the body of Clark Kent
at the moment in terms
of the ways that we think
and the ways that we act and
our existing business model.
And what I'm going to try
and show you over the next 20
minutes is how we can apply
platform thinking and platform
strategy to create a
significant commercial impact
and create a new way to
grow in the digital economy.
A bit of background--
Olly's already introduced me.
I won't go through
this in detail.
I've written a
book on this topic.
I work with the World Economic
Forum on their accelerating
digital transformation program.
And that is, again, about how
to help leaders and regulators
and government think differently
about the types of business
models that are going
to be most appropriate
in the digital world.
And I work with
execution partners
like Rainmaking, a big corporate
innovation company and venture
building company, to help
corporates move forward
with these principles.
And my experience is across
many sectors and geographies.
And I'll touch on examples
from these during the talk.
So the problem is summed up
by these three statistics
you can see here.
And my contention is that
digital transformation
wasn't making a big
impact before COVID.
COVID increases the importance
that we think differently
about how we operate
in a digital world.
But you can see these
three statistics here
from the surveys of C level
executives about 18 months ago.
They were worried that their
existing business models were
becoming increasingly unviable
as their [INAUDIBLE] digitizes
because that increases
competition, opens up
transparency about prices.
And as they try and
compete with their--
or keep up with consumer demands
and compete with other players,
it increases costs.
And in fact, 85% of
digital investments
deliver zero or negative
economic value add.
That's the profits
after cost of capital.
And as a result of
this, even before COVID,
executives were not particularly
happy with the innovation
efforts of their organization.
And now we're under
even more pressure.
The imperative to really
think differently and apply
new business models
is just even bigger.
And if you are an investor--
I'm sure all of you
are and you have
your own private investments--
working [INAUDIBLE]
companies are also investors.
Where do they place their bets?
What type of business
models would you
invest in compared to others?
And here's an example of
the returns of businesses
that operate a platform
business model at the top
there compared to, I guess,
more traditional tech companies
in the NASDAQ, the Dow
Jones, and, if you're
an incumbent organization
for a traditional industry,
you tend to be represented
by the bottom figure there.
So if you're thinking about
where you invest your money,
either as private
investors or as companies,
maybe there are new
types of business models
that you should be investing
in which have more resilience
and potential to grow.
And my contention is that
there's our platform business
model.
And every company needs
to fully embrace them
if they want to stay competitive
in a digital economy.
And then it begs
the question, well,
what do we mean by a
platform business model?
And this is a very
simple description of it.
It's a bit similar
to the one that Olly
showed showing that platform
businesses essentially
act as intermediaries between
people who've got solutions
and people who want solutions.
And if you're an
incumbent corporation,
you provide some
of those solutions.
But there are many other people
who could be complementary
for you to create solutions
that serve your customers.
And the aims of a
platform business
are to facilitate high
value transactions,
not just sell your own products,
and to create network effects
that mean that your business
is more valuable the more
people who use it.
That's why eBay and Uber
and Airbnb are so powerful.
They facilitate interactions.
And the more people who use it--
the more suppliers, the more
consumers-- the more
valuable it becomes.
And the key requirements
are that you
create an infrastructure,
like Olly said,
enabled by APIs is
really critical.
But anybody can plug
into your business.
Now, how that translates
if we go forward--
oh, yes.
I've a slight technical problem.
I hope you can see a picture of
a tweet by the CEO of Twitter.
Yes, hopefully you can see that.
Olly, can people see that?
I hope so.
OLIVER OGG: I'm probably
not the best person to ask,
because I've been having
problems, as well.
But yes, I can see it now.
Yeah.
SIMON TORRANCE: OK.
Good.
So the key essence of
a platform business
is summed up by this tweet
from the CEO of Airbnb
who said here, you can see it.
"Marriott wants to add
30,000 rooms this year.
We can do that in
the next two weeks."
And it sums up the essential
power of a platform business
model where you are leveraging
the assets of other people.
You don't have to build
hotels to be able to provide
a place for people to stay.
And for an incumbent
organization,
there are many options
for where you could
play in a platform economy.
You could create your
own platform business.
You could supply into
platform businesses.
You could use platforms to
supply you with services.
Or you could create
enabling capabilities
that you make available
into platforms
to help them run better.
And as Olly said, 30% of
global economic activity
is going to be mediated by
platforms in five years' time.
That creates an enormous
market for people
who've got-- who can create
enabling solutions that make
those platforms run better.
And financial services is
a golden example of this
to provide financial services
to support platform businesses.
So making this a bit more
tangible, what I've identified
is six main types of platform
plays for corporate businesses
and four types of
executional approaches.
This is really
critical, because it
helps to translate what can
feel like a very technical topic
to senior commercial execs
into something more tangible.
And I'll just
describe these quickly
and show you some examples.
So at the very,
very end there, you
could reinvent your
company entirely
and say we're going to become a
platform business, like Amazon
did and Apple did 20 years ago.
Or you can start more simply
on the bottom left here
and say, well, we're trying
to create digital solutions.
We don't have enough
capabilities and resources
in-house to do that.
How could we tap into the
thousands, if not hundreds
of thousands, of experts who
are out there in the world,
freelance experts, who we
could use to help us create
new digital solutions?
And that would be a
very legitimate way
of augmenting your
own capabilities
with third parties.
And some great example
I'm going to show you
in a minute of a
company who's done that.
You can create your
own digital solutions.
And those would be
software-based products
and services.
And most unicorns
start off doing that.
And then they evolve into
platform businesses over time.
Why can't we, as incumbent
businesses, create our own
unicorn businesses?
There's no reason.
We have any assets there.
There are a few
things missing, which
I'll describe in a second.
And of course, you can embed
your products and services
or your digital solutions
into other people's platforms.
You can create
online marketplaces,
like we heard with
Magalu in South America.
You can also
orchestrate completely
new ecosystems that are
emerging at the boundaries
between sectors.
As these boundaries
are blurring,
there are wonderful
opportunities
to create new
ecosystems that you can
orchestrate with a platform.
And in terms of the
way of executing,
the problem that many
traditional companies
have is they think we need
to build this internally.
It's a big IT project.
It's going to take five years.
And that's the wrong
approach entirely.
Occasionally you
can do something
like that where you have a
particular power to do so.
But there are other
approaches that
are complementary to that which
need to be part of the armory,
if you like.
So collaborating with startups
to help you speed up time
to market is really a very
powerful, legitimate way
to act.
You can buy in and acquire
companies to help you speed up
your activity.
And one of the best approaches
that I do a lot of work
with today is creating
your own external venture
outside of the
core business where
you can see a
market opportunity,
a bit like Arity we
heard from Olly just now.
But if we try and create that
within the core business,
we know it's going
to get suffocated.
Let's create a separate
venture with separate metrics,
new skills, hire new talent
to drive forward quickly
and effectively to grab
that market opportunity.
And that's a
particular capability
that is really important now
as things are moving so fast.
And here are a few
examples of companies
that bring to life some of
those examples I gave you there.
So I wouldn't go through
it all right now.
But I'm going to-- let's
just pick on a few here.
For General Electric,
it decided when
it was moving to be
a digital company,
digital industrial
company, it said,
we just don't have
the skills in-house
to create the
products and solutions
that our customers want.
And they created
a huge marketplace
to tap into the external
talent outside the walls
of their company.
So they could develop
products and services
for their customers.
Very powerful, very
practical platform
strategy, which delivered
about $7 billion of value
to the organization
over seven years.
I'm going to pick on a
few examples of companies
later on as I progress.
I just want to pick on a few.
Tinkoff Bank is one of
my favorite examples
of moments in the
financial services sector.
And it completely
revolutionized digital banking.
Started off being
a traditional bank
and it's created a whole
series of lifestyle ecosystems
around it and has the highest--
some of the highest metrics of
the banks in the world today
in terms of return on equity,
and so on and so forth.
And in the world of embedding
capabilities into the platform,
PayPal is obviously a
great example there.
PayPal enables nearly
every global platform--
or many global platforms
around the world.
So let's look at some examples.
And one of my favorites of
a traditional company that
has really embraced
platform thinking
is Ping An, which was--
and still is-- an
insurance company in China.
But these pie
charts you see here
represent how they shifted
or reallocated capital
to the new type
of business models
that I've just
been talking about.
In 2008, they were a
simple insurance company,
operating with that
type of business model.
By 2018, they had
reallocated capital,
management [INAUDIBLE],, and
skill to create a network
of ecosystem outside of
traditional financial
services--
in real estate, in buying and
selling cars, in health care,
remote health care.
And those ecosystems
enabled by platforms
have helped it-- have
helped it to grow way
beyond their
traditional competitors.
And I anticipate they'll do
more and more of that over time
and their business model
portfolio will evolve even more
to be even more powerful.
And you can see here, this is
their share price over time
here.
They're the blue.
They're now worth more than
Europe's biggest bank, HSBC.
HSBC used to own a
large stake in Ping An.
It sold that stake after
the last financial crisis.
Ping An has overtaken them,
is much more valuable,
and now has become the
biggest shareholder,
independent
shareholder, in HSBC.
And you can see HSBC's
trajectory compared to theirs.
And indeed, they
have outperformed
their local competitors.
It's not just,
well, that's China.
The application of
the business model
has helped them outcompete
Europe's biggest
bank and the local
competitors, as well.
And the key thing that has
driven it is leadership.
The leader said he looked at
how Alibaba and others were
operating and he said,
we want to emulate that.
He said, we're no longer
an insurance company.
We are now going to be a tech
company with financial services
licenses.
And they embraced
platform thinking.
And they've been
incredibly successful.
We'll come back and talk about
them maybe later on today.
So what does this
mean for leaders
and traditional companies?
Well, I wrote a book on
this called "FightBack."
And it's as much
about fighting back
against old ways of
thinking and acting
as it is against fighting back
against digital disruption.
And there are five key steps
to renew an incumbent business
model, to make it
fit for the future.
And particularly in
these times of crisis,
the imperative to apply these
principles is really strong.
And the first thing
is, we need to reset
the way our leaders think
about growth and value.
Most leaders of
incumbent businesses
have become successful
operating a certain type
of business model.
And the digital business
models that we've
been talking about just now
are often alien and different.
We need to rethink about the
ecosystems that are emerging
and where we could play
and our roles within that.
And this comes back to the
way of executing, as well.
We can't just try and
execute everything
from within the core business.
We need to reallocate capital,
as we heard from Ping An,
in a different way,
and put our money
where our mouth is if we really
want to be a digital player.
And probably the
most crucial thing--
we cannot do disruptive
innovation from within the core
business.
It rarely works.
We need to create an
ambidextrous, two-handed
organization and
provide the space
for new digital businesses
to take off, like we heard
from Arity from earlier on.
They can access the assets
of the core business,
but they have different
[INAUDIBLE],, different metrics,
different space in
which they can operate,
often equity-based ventures.
This is how Ping An did it.
It created separate
equity based ventures,
which attracted A-grade
entrepreneurs to drive them
forward but connected them
back to the core business
and allowed the core
business to control them.
They weren't third
party investments.
And then finally, if
we do this, we can,
like [INAUDIBLE] have
done, is widen our scope,
be more involved in more
parts that our customers like,
and deliver much
more value to them.
Now, we'll end with one tip
and a couple of case studies.
And then we'll open
up for a discussion.
One of the most
challenging things
when you are trying to describe
these types of new business
models is making it tangible
for the leaders of the business
units in the core business.
They have all the power.
They run the business.
They have the budgets.
And they have all
the assets that you
would love to leverage.
And one thing I
find very effective
is to sit down with the leaders
of the existing business units
and show how, by creating
digital platform businesses,
whether they're internal or
they're separate ventures,
we can increase the
revenue or the core metrics
that are important
for the core business
by significant amounts.
And we can show how we can do
that to defend their business,
create new revenue.
What are the metrics that
are important to them?
And here's an example I worked
on with an insurance company
to show over five years how
we could create a material
difference to their business by
applying the principles I just
described today.
And I'll give you a
couple of examples here,
how it is possible for any--
my belief-- any
business in any sector
to create a
significant new growth
path if they can
remove the blinkers
and apply some of the principles
and methods I talked about.
And FLSmidth is a very
large mining company
that wanted to say--
wanted you to ask
yourself, how do we
create 20% net new growth
over the next five years?
And by applying the
principles I talked about,
envisaging new ecosystems
and spotting opportunities
to apply those
different platform
plays and the different
ways of executing,
they identified $3 billion
of new growth opportunity
over the next five years.
Now, the other example
I want to share with you
is a small insurance
company that said,
we need to be engaging
with millennials.
They don't buy insurance.
They don't look to the future.
We know that they
will be most of-- they
will make up the majority of the
insurance market in a few years
time.
How do we engage with them?
We don't have the
skills to do that.
And they created a
separate joint venture
with entrepreneurs with
separate equity structure--
separate equity structure
to tackle that market.
And that's been
incredibly successful.
And they're on track
for a significant impact
to their core business.
And they've done
it at record speed,
something that
would be impossible
within the core business.
And then finally,
probably the best example
of the ambidextrous organization
being put in place--
BP, knowing that
fundamentally fossil fuels
are under significant threat
over the next-- no one
wants fossil fuels over
the next 10, 20 years.
They said, we cannot innovate.
We need to change
the way we innovate.
It's not making an impact.
They created a separate unit
called Launchpad in which they
said, we're going to create
five unicorn businesses
over the next five years,
so that [INAUDIBLE]
those businesses need
to add 5% to the EBITDA of
our core business, as well.
So they created a
future business metric
and they said, to engage the
leaders of the core business,
we are going to add value to
you over this period, as well.
This is not innovation theater
something a long way away
from the core.
This is about-- we're
changing the whole business
so we can be [INAUDIBLE] for
a different sort of future.
They put their
deputy CEO in charge
and it's one of
the best examples
I can see today
of really applying
the ambidextrous approach
and being committed to it.
So thank you very much for
your attention this morning
and looking forward to
discussing this with you.
It's all about
how we can release
the inner digital Superman
from the wonderful assets
and capabilities
we have, which tend
to be locked inside our Clark
Kent, which exemplifies how
most businesses, incumbent
businesses, operate and think
today.
Thank you.
OLIVER OGG: Thank you, Simon.
And that's many fabulous
insights shared there.
So this is our opportunity
now to take some questions
from the audience.
First of all, from Roland--
there's a perspective--
sorry, from your perspective
of working amongst
European corporates,
do you think too many are
waiting for or expecting
the EU to assist either
financially with innovation
or controlling through
regulation, as opposed
to corporates
actually being braver
and starting out and perhaps
leveraging a first mover
advantage?
I think Simon would be
best to answer that.
SIMON TORRANCE: Yeah, it's
a really good question.
So obviously we don't want
to wait for regulators
to do anything, because that
would be a recipe for disaster.
However-- however-- we do
need to help regulators create
the right regulatory
environments, which
are fair and reasonable.
And we need to help
governments, as well,
create the right
industrial structures,
for particularly European
economy to thrive.
And the problem we
have at the moment
is that because traditional
European corporates are not
so sophisticated about
the digital world
as some of the big
digital giants,
their lobbying skills
are less powerful.
And so we need to upgrade
our knowledge of how
digital business models,
like the ones I've mentioned,
operate, so that we as
industrial European companies
can lobby more effectively and
help governments and regulators
create more effective structures
for innovation to happen.
And it's quite interesting.
In the financial sector,
PSD2 has been a regulation
to open up our data,
customer data, from banks
to allow people to
innovate on top of it.
And that's created a whole
flurry of wonderful innovation
in the fintech world.
And we may well see
that type of regulation
applied to the big tech giants
to force them to open up access
to data.
That's coming through at
the moment through data
portability.
So we need to--
absolutely, we need
to take the bull by the horns
and innovate for ourselves.
And I think we need a more
sophisticated discussion
with government
regulators, as well.
OLIVER OGG: Fantastic.
And a great question
here from Dorita--
apologies if I've not
said that correctly.
Do you always need to have a
visionary leader at the top?
Otherwise, how do
you approach making
a case for the investment
into a transformation
into a platform
business where the ROI
is difficult to estimate?
And in some business
cultures, financial numbers
have to stack up front.
Very interesting.
And by the way, I was on a
conversation with a cohort
of banking leaders yesterday.
And we were talking
about DBS in Singapore,
who launched 150 APIs as
part of their go to market.
And the position there
is that they don't
want to be front and center.
They don't want to be
owning all these channels.
They want to be invisible.
And that's their strategy.
And I can't imagine there
was ever a proposed business
case with hard numbers
behind something like that.
But Simon, any thoughts?
SIMON TORRANCE: Well,
you're quite right.
The question is a very good one.
So sometimes the business
does have a visionary leader.
Now, the danger
sometimes is that leader
can be too visionary.
And if they don't pull along
with them, the shareholders
and the rest of
the organization,
that can cause a lot of trouble.
In the case of Ping An,
the leader is a visionary.
And he's the founder
of the company.
He's an entrepreneur.
So for him, he's
got that power--
like Jeff Bezos-- to
make things happen.
But most traditional, industrial
companies don't necessarily
have that in place.
And we tend to
have what we might
call caretaker managers, who
are very successful operators
of existing business models.
And their job tends to
be very focused on what
the shareholders or the pension
funds are acquiring from them.
So we need some
parallel activity.
We do need a new discussion
with the shareholders
to allow us to do new things.
But probably first we need
to prove that new business
models can deliver value.
And that's why I was
saying before one
of the good techniques is to
work with the existing business
leaders to show how the
platform activity can
deliver a meaningful impact.
And that's a difficult thing
to do, but it can be done.
And it's an important
part of the process.
Now, occasionally you
might say, well, it's
a no brainer to do APIs.
And I think that is
correct, because it
can facilitate so many things.
And it's not a huge cost.
But to really get the
organization to move forward,
you need to have a grown up
discussion showing practically
how platform business models
can affect the core metrics.
And indeed, one of the
best ways of doing that
is to create external
ventures where
you can fast track something
quickly into the market.
And that demonstrates
the art of the possible.
We've now done it three times--
like the example from
the Danish insurer there.
We've created this venture.
And already it's
worth a lot of money.
It's delivering a lot of value.
Wouldn't it be great if we
could do 10 more of these?
And that demonstrates the
art of the possible-- help
the leaders of the core
business become more confident.
And it's something they can
show to the shareholders
to illustrate what can be done.
OLIVER OGG: Fantastic.
So let's [INAUDIBLE]
chat between ourselves.
But I am keeping an eye on these
questions as they flow through.
And I'm going to lean on some of
these, because they're spot on.
And I think that point
about executive leadership,
but also proving [INAUDIBLE]
is always hot topics.
I mean, I think even pre-COVID.
There's another question
actually about quick wins
from a platform strategy.
I think you've kind
of touched on that,
how to demonstrate something
relatively quickly within.
And this individual's asking
between [INAUDIBLE] pretty
tight.
And one of the things
I've certainly learned
is a lot of
businesses are already
trying to work efficiently,
or more efficiently,
with partners.
So perhaps let's not focus
on unknown innovation first.
Let's perhaps think about, who
are the partners that you're
working with or work
with imminently,
and let's do this in
and interesting ways.
And there I think more immediate
things can be shown at pace.
I mean, Simon, any
reflections on that comment?
SIMON TORRANCE: Well, you can,
but that's sort of incremental.
I mean, it's necessary
but insufficient.
It's not going to
move the needle.
And you've seen--
I just showed you
the share prices of the DAX.
It's the same with the FTSE.
All incumbent businesses
are not doing well.
The ones that are
doing well are the ones
that have invested in
platform business models.
And Apple and [INAUDIBLE]
didn't start out with that.
They added it to their business
model 10 or 20 years ago.
So absolutely you need
to be more efficient.
You need to improve the way you
serve your existing companies
and optimize your
existing business model.
Absolutely.
That's critical.
But if you don't do the
other thing, the other part
of the ambidextrous
activity, you're
just in a race with your
competitors getting nowhere.
So you do need to do
both of these things.
And rather than put virtually
no investments on this side,
or a tiny bit of--
let's throw a bit of money
to the innovation team.
Like BP has done, you
need to say, right,
we're going to put
$500 million here
to create five
unicorns, while also
driving value for the key
metric, which is the EBITDA
margin.
And that is a very bold and
the most appropriate approach,
doing both activities
and committing
to both at the same time.
OLIVER OGG: And
with Launch Pad--
so significant ambition there.
But are any of those
ventures likely to erode any
of the existing [INAUDIBLE]?
Because I think one of the
challenges I've often seen
is that classic
innovator's dilemma
where there's a new
venture being proposed.
There's certainly interest
and excitement around it.
But there's concern
that ultimately it's
going to disrupt a revenue line
that actually might be quite
profitable, even when they
know that that revenue is
potentially at risk,
if not at risk.
SIMON TORRANCE: Yeah.
So it's a very good
question, and particularly
in the retail sector,
when retailers
think about creating
online marketplaces, which
is essentially allowing
third parties--
maybe competitors, as
well-- to sell through you
to your customers.
And even Amazon have
this debate internally.
Should we open up
to third parties
rather than buying the inventory
ourselves and sell it all?
And they had the foresight
to look ahead and said, well,
what do our customers
really want?
Let's think about our
customer, not about us.
And our customers want
choice and a selection.
And we can't.
We don't have the
money or the capability
to provide everything for
our customers ourselves.
So by looking ahead, focusing
on what customers needed,
and understanding how the
internet and digital technology
could enable that through APIs
20 years ago, as you said,
they said, well, let's
believe in this vision
and make it happen.
Now, in practice,
how you execute
that needs to be
done very carefully
and the third party partners
or complementary service
providers you choose
to start with,
you might choose those that
are not directly competitive.
And over time, as you're
growing the knowledge and skills
of how to curate a marketplace,
then you might open up further.
And that's what a lot
of the second wave
of traditional retailers
have learned how to do.
So yes, there is a potential
threat of cannibalization.
But it can easily be managed if
you think it through properly.
And indeed, in the case of
BP, none of those businesses
are threatening
the core business.
In fact, as I said, they
have been explicitly set up
to drive 5% EBITDA improvement
to the core business.
So it's actually the opposite.
They're designed specifically
to deliver that value there as
well as separate
value for themselves.
OLIVER OGG: Great.
Thank you.
You talked about the value that
incumbents might be sitting on.
And the danger, I
guess, is that there
can be an ego around the brand.
And actually, I
just talked about--
I just mentioned
that example of DHS,
where they want to be invisible.
I mean, that's quite an
extraordinary statement
for a bank to make,
where often they
want to be front and center.
You know, the brand is a
compelling gravitational pull.
Everybody wants to kind
of own that relationship
with a customer.
What do you think are the
assets for an incumbent
and what are the
liabilities for an incumbent
when thinking of a
platform strategy?
SIMON TORRANCE: Yeah.
It's a very good question.
So again, what you need to do
is have a vision of the future.
So if you don't have
that and you're always
looking at the
present or the past
and trying to extrapolate
from the past,
then you tend to be trapped
in the mindsets which
are not going to be helpful.
So as you say,
banks often say, we
want to own the
customer relationship.
We want-- it's our ego.
We want everybody to come
through us for the services.
And that's pretty dangerous.
If, as opposed to that,
you look into the future
and, for example, you see
that in five or 10 years time,
platforms are going
to be mediating
30% of all economic
activity-- about $60 trillion.
So rather than you trying
to compete with people
who are much better
at managing customer
relationships, like
DBS has done, you say,
why don't we enable it?
Why don't we embed
our capabilities
into other people's businesses?
And in fact, just
this is one example.
The market for what's
called embedded finance--
so that's financial
services embedded
at the point of purchase.
If you want to go
get an online MBA,
you want to get a loan
right there and then
that can be given to
you there and then
without having to call up a
bank and try and sort it out,
or you're seeing more
of this in terms of,
you want to buy
a product but you
want to pay for it in
installments over a year.
And this market of
embedded finance--
I did some analysis of
this the other day--
it is potentially more
valuable than the whole
of the global software
market in five or 10 years
time, because
everything is being--
there's an explosion
of digital services.
And we all need to pay
for them or exchange value
related to them.
And so it's a clever
move by DBS to say,
actually, we can see the future.
And we want to enable it
being in the background
rather than trying to
compete with companies
who are much better at
controlling the customer
interface.
Now, that's one strategy.
Ping An has taken a
slightly different strategy.
And both of these
can be complementary.
If I was talking to a
bank, I'd say do both.
Ping An said, we want to
create deeper relationships
with our customers.
So let's create some
platforms and ecosystems
in areas of their
lifestyle that we normally
don't participate in terms
of buying and selling cars.
Let's create a
marketplace for that.
Or a remote health care
telemedicine platform,
which has obviously taken
off like crazy with COVID.
And they created these
separate ventures just
for the opposite
reason of DBS, so they
could be at the center
of those experiences
and those could act as a channel
for their financial services.
But interestingly, they created
separate brands for those,
because they knew that
those brands needed to be--
people didn't affiliate Ping
An with buying and selling cars
and so on.
So they created separate
entities, separate brands.
They control them.
Some of those they've IPOed.
But they've created, as a
result, this incredible network
or ecosystem of
platforms that are all
connected by one single
sign on mechanism
and an API structure
behind it that allows them
to intermesh across all of it.
That's probably one
of the best examples
of tackling the question
you just asked there.
OLIVER OGG: I often like
that example from Arity
where they are now
signing up competitors
to their parent because they
realized-- they've recognized
this for years,
but more data means
they can provide more insights,
which means more value, which
makes them just more
compelling, this kind
of gravitational pull,
flywheel effect around data.
And I guess we often
talk about data
being the new world as a cliche.
But it's that combination
of data and models, so i.e.
the automatic insight
being generated out
of the vast amounts
of data is going
to be their defensive
wall as they open up
and emerge into all these
other different touch
points and industries.
I think perhaps one
more question for me,
and then I'm keeping an eye
on the audience questions.
So this is a challenging
time for, obviously,
many industries.
We've just been actually
working with a retailer that's
seen 90% drop in their revenue.
But they recognize the
importance of that API strategy
as a defensive and
an offensive tactic.
I often feel like there's this
sweet spot for an incumbent.
It has appetites.
If there's too much kind
of competitive pressure,
they can default to safety.
And if there's not enough,
this other end of the scale,
they kind of [INAUDIBLE].
Now, because of the situation
now, I guess a lot of things
are being shaken up.
What do you think will
be compelling messages
that our audience
could take away
around this situational
awareness that we currently
have, this kind of
landscape that we have,
where so many industries
have been disrupted?
What do you think
could be the three
things to call out that would
be compelling messages going
forward?
SIMON TORRANCE: I think one
of the most useful things
to do at this time
of the crisis is
to spend a little bit of
time zooming out, zooming out
from all the pressures
of the core business
and looking to the future,
because the crisis is just
accelerating
digitalization, as we know,
and certain sectors
more than others.
And if you've got--
one of my colleagues gave this
great suggestion the other day.
He said, why don't you just
apply 0.1% of your employees
to look at the future?
That can be, like, 40 people.
Can you afford 40 people--
some of them could be on
furlough doing nothing--
to look into the future?
Because if we don't do
that, we're acting blind.
It's like walking
forward without knowing
what the future is like.
And we need to ask the
difficult questions.
How quickly is cash
going to disappear?
If you're in financial
services or retail,
that's a really
critical question.
If you're a retailer--
if you don't have an
online marketplace, which
is a type of
platform, how are you
going to compete with
others that have got that?
I mean, if you did have
it in the COVID crisis,
you'd be doing really
well, like those that do.
So allocate-- it's not much.
But allocate some people
to look into that future
and translate it for
the leaders of today
so they can really understand
it and internalize it.
And everybody's got enough
resources to do that.
That would be the one most
important thing to do.
And understand the
business models
that are likely to be most
effective in that world, which
will be those that
connect people together,
platform-based business models.
And then try and
translate what that
means to the core business.
And look at those
different types of platform
plays I described and
the different ways
of executing them.
And create a plan that can
apply those to our business.
And finally, make it tangible
for the existing business
owners.
So if we do this,
like BP has done,
we expect or we will plan
for this type of impact
on the core business,
as well as keeping
us fit for the future
in the, if you like,
the invent the future
part of the business.
OLIVER OGG: Fabulous.
That resonates
with some reading I
was doing around
the companies that
struggled after the financial
crisis and those that actually
did reasonably well
after the crisis.
And it was
interesting to reflect
that those that did kind of
broadside horizontal cost
cutting and didn't invest in
these specific opportunities
were three times less
successful than those that
took an opportunity to
cut costs in some areas
but also think about the future.
And [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so we're coming
up towards the end.
So let's move to just
another slot for Q&A. Here's
a question.
It's a bit of a classic.
And I think we touched
on some of this already.
But I mean, how do you
position a platform strategy
in a traditional company
[INAUDIBLE] CEO and the board
down are very conservative?
SIMON TORRANCE: Well, you've
got to spend time with them.
It's like any type of education.
Make it tangible
to them and show
how it can impact the figures or
the numbers that interest them.
So again, I go
back to that chart
with the insurance
company saying,
your current growth plans
show this trajectory.
Well, maybe, at the
moment, it's a negative.
And here, if you did
these things here,
we believe it can deliver this.
And that's the type of
interesting discussion
you'd have.
If you just do it on theory
and ideas and concepts
that they've never heard or
they're not familiar with,
then it tends to go in
one ear and out the other.
So we need to make it tangible
for those types of people
and put it in language that
is motivating for them.
OLIVER OGG: Thank you.
Grace-- sorry, I'm just
scanning the questions here.
Yeah, OK.
I guess if I can--
perhaps another one.
What kind of
platform types do you
think are resonating
with the C-suites
that you're talking
to right now?
I mean, you talked about, let's
say, markets and external--
marketplaces and
external ventures.
What do you think are
particularly compelling right
now?
SIMON TORRANCE: Yeah, so
it's a very good question.
It depends on the sector.
So if you take retail, if
you don't have a marketplace,
online marketplace, you're
just not able to compete.
When your customers
want something
and then they can't
find it on your site,
they default back to
Amazon, of course.
So if you're in retail,
just being in the game
means you need a marketplace.
But I mean, that's
just to be in the game.
What I think is relevant
for all sectors is to--
often people think about
platforms as being,
let's create the Uber
or Airbnb of our sector.
That's really difficult
and most of those fail.
The better starting
point is when you say,
let's create a
digital solution that
solves a really big
problem for our customers.
And if we design that right,
it can be a point solution
to start with.
But like any
software business, it
can evolve into more of a
platform, open platform,
over time.
But that tends to be
the way that the unicorn
businesses started out.
They solve a particular problem
first and then they expand.
And I would recommend
for most companies
and most sectors is create
a portfolio of those.
That's what BP is
doing at the moment.
They're not trying to
create the Uber of energy.
Way too complicated.
From very practical
digital solutions
that are addressing
a big, big problem
in the market that
can also drive value
to the core business.
And that would be my single
biggest recommendation.
If you remember the types
of platforms I talked about,
the bottom two are probably
the best to start with.
If you're in financial
services, think
about [INAUDIBLE] finance.
If you're in retail, you
need a marketplace just
to be in the game.
But you need a combination
of those things.
And you need a
separate organization
in which to build them.
OLIVER OGG: Thank you, Simon.
And what I love about
that is just the message.
McKinsey recently in an article
about digital transformation
in the time of crisis talked
about the mandate to be bold.
So I think that's a great
place to end today's session.
Thank you for everyone
for the questions today.
I hope you've found that session
both helpful, interesting,
and useful.
We would also love to hear
your feedback on this event.
So please do send your
ideas and suggestions
through the feedback link here.
Do stay tuned.
Next online meetup
will be in September.
So please share your
thoughts so we can make
the next edition even better.
Thank you for your time.
I look forward to
seeing you next time.